the Benghazi story that they were doing
with Hillary Clinton yeah Benghazi
Benghazi Benghazi Benghazi Benghazi
emails emails emails emails emails
emails couldn't that be a very similar
situation I don't know why why don't
deflect stay on this I'm not deflecting
what I'm saying stay on this that she's
a criminal and that's validated yeah
people around her commit suicides too
often wait that's why that's it that and
by the way she's one of the most feared
people in politics not him people love
Bill Clinton they fear her do I know 100
no but if 74 whatever the number is if
50 people around you if 10 people around
you keep committing suicide I'm a little
bit concerned I watch this documentary
400 people that this nurse was looking
at they made a documentary whatever they
call this guy the movie came out the the
good nurse 400 people died because
they're taking a drug this guy
eventually went to jail the difference
between her is she controls all these
political organizations so she's not
gonna be going to jail it's not going to
happen to how many people 57 people from
Clinton's Inner Circle have died in a
strange Circumstance the last 30 years
yeah it's a weird number brother I mean
the other day Steph Curry made five full
court shots with one hand did you see
this it got I was fake I thought it was
fake everybody shocked
with one hand he made five full court
shots this guy's the greatest shooter of
all time when he did this yeah when you
see something like that with Hillary
there's odds are there's something going
out there so going back to this to say
whether it's illegal or not and beat
around the bush with the story what they
did is election fraud that's the
definition of it
what's your level of certainty that she
is a murderer my level of certainty in
life works in the following way I play
with odds just like I do in Investments
sure I bought an mbappe card his most
expensive car two months ago the reason
why I bought an mbappe car two months
ago is because I think that guy's a
badass mother you know what and he's
showing you right now and guess what he
just officially tied the messy and I
think one more than Ronaldo or something
like that for the most goals ever in the
world cup by player and he's only 23
years old those guys are in the late 30s
okay his card that I bought doubled in
price in the last two months okay that's
an odds game okay that I'm playing
investment if I talk to my kids and last
night the five Fresca's are missing and
Melva tells me five Frescas are missing
and I'm sitting there interrogating
these kids to see who had the three
Frescas we know we ended up finding God
because of odds based on who likes
Fresca demos and who's an expert in that
area Okay So eventually we got the Intel
I went to my Twitter files in my house
and found out who drank the most Fresca
and the guy eventually admitted to it
who it was okay so it wasn't Senna but
the point with something like this with
Hillary 54 people yeah I mean you're
naive if you think it's a good idea to
get into her Inner Circle you're very
nice naive person if you think it's a
honorable thing to go work for somebody
like that when you see what happened
with Twitter and saying I don't think it
would have made a difference in election
you're either naive or the following and
by the way this is what I'm about to
tell you right now I'm giving you a bone
okay and you can pick this and play with
it all you want you ready all of us to
an extent have selective hearing
we can only see the good our kids do
great parents understand that their kids
do things wrong and they got to be
disciplined either by their teacher by
their coach or people around them okay
great parents
sometimes we only see good in everybody
sometimes we don't want the story to
come out because we hate Trump so we
don't want to give him any credit for
anything God forbid if this story
validates that Trump should have been
president and I'm wrong today and I
gotta go pay back all the people I took
money from sometimes we don't like that
story right okay
but in reality this is a real story okay
and a lot of people that voted for him
are going back to Walmart asking for
refund right now saying I want my vote
back they're not happy about their vote
but there are those who secretly they're
so proud that they publicly looked so
good when Trump lost they can't give in
to this thing to give it any kind of
credence because God forbid if they do
guess what they were wrong we hate to be
wrong cannot stand buyers remorse but a
lot of people got buyers remorse we can
move on to the next door get a little
pushback I love you I respect you you're
my mentor you're my boss you didn't give
me the odds though what are the odds
that she's a murderer oh you're going
into that you didn't answer the question
you told me who found them yes I think
that's a fair I'll give you the answer
what are the odds that she's involved in
those 54 people that committed suicide I
don't know bro I'm in the 60 percentile
okay yeah by the way I appreciate that
number because we learned something when
we interviewed the Phillip mods former
CI and this is something that I I
constantly constantly navigate to and I
implore the audience to use this as well
there's a major difference between what
you think and what you know and what you
can prove yeah and nobody's proved that
she's done that well if you're given 60
no no I'm saying 60 but let me tell you
but there's people out there that are
like 100 bro I know for a fact bro
but 54 people there's a little bit of
smoke
people would follow that Adam if 54 of
my sales people had committed and they
were their direct reports of mine you
should reconsider I know I know so what
all the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of valuetainment
it says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
or black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
thank you
[Music]